i'll i'll get this series started
so i'm my name is neha
and i work at aws
and essentially today i'm talking about
how we're making verification the new
normal
for all aws customers and to start we
actually extended the definition
of verification itself so we want to
enable millions of aws customers to
prove
correctness of their systems with
respect to their specification
so today customers can go to the aws
console
and use compute analytics storage and
database services to build
applications uh store data and even run
their workloads
and access to all these services and
resources
in aws is governed by policies written
in a domain specific language
and customers actually have requirements
around who should have access to what
so we go okay policies seem like a great
verification target
so how do we get the specification we
can't get millions of aws users to write
specifications
though we did try and it didn't go so
great
the key insight is we need to infer
specifications automatically
but do it in a way that is customized to
each user themselves
and the first application of this that
i'm going to talk about is
block public access it's a preventative
control
and it's verifying whether a policy
grants unrestricted public access
to untrusted entities and
how do we get this set of untrusted
entities they can be different for
different users
again we can't expect them to write the
list in the set of untrusted entities
and provide it
or even go back and annotate all the
legacy policies to say what is untrusted
so let's look at an example to dive into
what do we mean
by untrusted entity so here
the username admin is an untrusted
entity
because anybody can create a user name
admin
in their account but the source vpc
abcde is a trusted entity because it's
value
it's based on an identifier of your
private network
and it's set by the system so our
insight here
is that we can automatically infer the
trusted entities
from the policies themselves and
coming up with a precise definition of
what these trusted key value pairs are
actually requires significant domain
expertise and knowledge and work
for example the value of this source vpc
if it was a wild card
then it would not be a trusted entity
because it's saying allow any source vpc
but even though it requires all this
extensive knowledge
it needs to be created once and can be
used many times
so once we have these the next thing we
do is we take our policy
and turn it into an smt formula using a
tool we have called zelkova
and here the set of all satisfying
assignments
uh in the formula correspond to the set
of
requests or accesses that are allowed by
the policy
so a request is allowed by a policy if
it matches one of the allow statements
and
doesn't match one of the deny statements
and then finally to evaluate whether the
policy does grant unrestricted public
access
we check the satisfiability of this
formula that says
is it allowed and is it uh is it part of
one of the untrusted
entities so and you can read more about
how we do it in an upcoming fsc
paper but the key here is it is
integrated into
amazon s3 and this integration needed to
satisfy the operational requirements of
s3
security availability uh robustness
the other key here is the computational
complexity of the problem
makes the pathological cases unavoidable
and to maintain
soundness we choose to fail closed which
means
if the analysis returns unknown because
the analysis timed out
we say the policy is public
so this is great right like so how how
do we take it a step further
and taking the idea of inferring
specification to the next
level is what we did in access analyzer
here customers want more granular
capabilities
not just public access but
they want to say does an external entity
x
have access access and we can't
again expect them to write bespoke
specifications does lee have access does
nathan have access
first you have to think about oh do i
even know the people that i want to be
able to ask access
to so what access analyzer does
it removes this upfront work of having
users to write the specifications to say
ensure that lee does not have access in
fact it generates findings
to tell you hey lee has access
did you intend for that to happen and
now it's flipped your notion because
instead of you having to think and write
about this you're given this very
declarative statement and you can say
yes or no and it captures your intent
into the specification and then you can
use this tool
and the the thing is you can read
how we did it like it's it's we use you
know techniques from predicate
abstraction
and there was a talk yesterday by andrew
gasik who who presented this work
and you can you know read more about it
in the paper
and these tools really resonate with
customers who
who can leverage the power of
verification
without needing to be an expert in the
area
and before i wrap up i just want to
provide you
something that we are working on right
now and that is to say how do we even
synthesize permissions from the get-go
and this is an example application that
operates on an s3 bucket making a few
api calls
and we do a data flow analysis to
automatically extract the permissions
needed by this application and here you
can essentially get the right
permissions to begin with
so the takeaway here is to make
verification accessible to millions of
aws customers
you really have to think how can we
extract
infer specifications which to them is
their intent
and make it customizable to their use
case
and make it available at scale where
they don't have to think about
what they're saying or asking but it is
integrated in their
regular workflows so this is exciting
they're hiring for internships full-time
positions
and you know you want to have an impact
work with millions of aws customers
you know email us email me email this uh
other email
uh on cap20 so
at the there's also this this work i
talked about like
how aws is doing verification but we
have equally exciting work going on in
prime video
on how formal verification is being used
so i'm going to hand it over to jim
christie who's
um who manages a team in london uk
and we'll talk tell you all about the
work there
all right thanks very much neha i'm
gonna try and take over the screen
i do that take over
all right perfect hopefully you can see
my screen
i'm just going to get into presentation
mode
all right it's cool so yeah so my name
is jim christie um
i'm a software development manager at
amazon
uh i've been in prime video for um for
just over eight years
so yes i'm not an applied scientist so
if you do have questions at the end
please make sure that they're easy um so
yeah so
in the time i've been at amazon i've
managed a few different kinds of teams
i started out managing back end service
teams and then i moved over to
manager native client team and now i'm
managing a really different team an
automated reasoning team
and my team's kind of unique in that
it's it's got a fairly even split of
software engineers and applied
scientists and so when we started the
team
we decided that we we wanted to you know
have software engineers collaborating
with applied scientists to help them
build you know production quality
software that
would cope with with amazon's scale
problems
all right so first you know what's
what's prime video
so prime video is a global streaming
video service
and we offer you know subscriptions and
paid for on-demand content across the
world
and our customers use a range of a range
of devices to get to us
so they use you know mobile devices they
get to us via the website
and they use what we call living room
devices um so these are things like
smart tvs set top boxes consoles and
streaming sticks
all right so prime videos is really
focused on
on delivering high quality software um
and we use a range you know a range of
techniques um
so we use you know test suites we use
full ci cd pipelines we have
device testing labs and we have our own
client ui testing frameworks that we've
built ourselves
and and now you know after speaking to
byron cook we're now using static
analysis as well
um and uh and you know we uh we kind of
decided that
it would be great to be able to improve
quality without having to write more
tests
now don't get me wrong you know i'm not
saying there's uh
that there's there's anything wrong with
tests we we really do value tests
um but we also recognize that they're
quite expensive
um so this is a this picture on the
screen now is is the test pyramid
and some of you might have seen this
before um and the basic idea is that
you know you should put a lot of your
investment into into unit tests because
they're fairly cheap to write and
they're fairly easy to maintain
and then you should have a healthy chunk
of integration tests and they're a
little bit harder to do they're a little
bit more brittle harder to maintain a
little bit more expensive
and then at the top of the pyramid you
have manual tests these are really
expensive you know you need a person to
actually
run the tests and click on buttons and
they can take a long time
and they can really slow releases down
um so we try and avoid those at all
costs
but with with static analysis what we
wanted to do was to
was to take this goal of compressing the
test pyramid
and complement traditional testing and
you know also the main aim with it is to
automatically catch issues
before they hit production
all right so i wanted to show you a a
very simplified view of
of the prime video software stack um so
what we've got here at the bottom is is
the customer's home
and in the customer's home they have
another fancy tv or a console
and on that device is our native ui
rendering and playback framework
and this is responsible for things like
storage and crypto and drm
um rendering and playback initialization
so when the prime video app starts what
it does is it pulls
down the latest javascript client from
from the amazon cloud and that then
starts communicating over the public
internet
with the orchestration layer and the
backend services and
marshalling and proxying all sorts of
different requests for content and
and ui layouts and things like that
all right so that's a little overview of
our stack
and then so some of the challenges that
we face uh you know delivering our app
to millions of customers are
you know the native rendering frameworks
very hard to update
it ships with the devices from
third-party manufacturers to the stores
um and you know to put an update out to
the native client sometimes involves us
negotiating with a with a third-party
device manufacturer
um so you know this is really mission
critical code
we don't have the option to just roll it
back it's not like a back-end service
um we also have you know our app is now
on thousands of different
unique device types and it's not just
hard it's impossible for us to to
manually test
every change works with every device
it's just not possible
we have hundreds of software engineering
teams just in prime video
and we have you know have over a
thousand software engineers and they're
all effectively working on the same
product
um now these teams have done a great job
of of kind of creating architectural
boundaries
um but when one team makes uh makes a
change that another team doesn't expect
it can result in a bad customer
experience of course at the forefront of
our minds and i've got it involved
is you know we want to keep our millions
of customers happy
um all right so how do we do that so you
know amazon's amazon's overall goal
is to be earth's most customer-centric
company
um and you know what we do you know we
like to um
to help us sort of focus on building the
right things we have this mechanism
called working backwards
and the idea is that to start building
solutions we really need to make sure
we're solving a real problem um and we
do that by
actually trying to speak to our
customers or get into our customers
mindset
and for my team you know we're really
lucky because our customers are other
software engineers
and we can just go and sit at their
desks and ask them questions
so that's what we do and that's what we
did when we started the team we went and
identified some some real problems that
our
our engineers were facing so once we've
kind of defined a
solution we can ask the customer for
feedback you know does it really solve
their problem
and then of course we can it gives us
the confidence to then go and design
develop deploy um software that
fits the bill that we can then track
measure and improve over time
all right so what is the problem we're
solving um so there's a couple
but overall you know we're trying to
maintain this really high quality
bar for our software so that we can keep
our end customers happy
and prevent them having bad experiences
so static analysis is great at catching
bugs which is really hard to write tests
for
but it's actually very hard to mechanize
static analysis
it's hard to get teams to fix backlogs
of issues
you know they're really busy they've got
big road maps they've got lots of things
to deliver
and it's just really hard for them to
prioritize
fixing code fixing problems in the code
which has probably been in the code base
for a long time
so you know we think there's uh we think
there's various sweet spots within the
the developer workflow
starting with local command line tools
and then in code review analysis and
then in the cd pipeline quality gates
and so my team decided to start with the
code review as our sweet spot
and so we built an automated code review
bot called bugbear
and what bugbear does is it listens out
for customer code-based changes
listens for code reviews and then it
pulls the code and builds it
and sends it off to facebook's awesome
infer
and when we get the analysis results
back from infer
we chop it up compare it with the diff
and post it back to the to the code
review as comments
to say hey you know hey here's a here's
a race conditioner here's a null pointer
exception
and this works really well because the
developer has the context they're
incentivized to fix the bug before
it gets pushed out to production um and
you know we chose
joe's infer because it's really easy to
use it's easy to integrate with and
it biases towards less noisy results
which equals
less angry engineers which equals more
bugs get fixed
um so we're not just we're not just
using facebook's infer we're also
building our own
custom analyzers um so we built our own
product called coast guard so this is
what the applied scientists
in the team have been have been busy
with um and
and coast guard's kind of looking at um
so coast guard's already
also run by bug bear and also listens
out for code reviews
who's looking for different things it's
not looking for no pointers it's looking
for um
you know results that are very specific
to prime video code
so we're looking for integration uh bugs
between
different architectural boundaries and
so there's these critical points in the
stack where
these teams integrate with each other
and so we built our own analyzer to
reason about
that integration in the different layers
of the stack
so we decided to start out with our
mission critical code which i introduced
you to before
and and the view that i showed you
before isn't quite the whole story
so we have this native ui rendering and
playback framework
um and to get it onto third-party
devices
requires third-party assistance um
sometimes we do this
uh within within prime video but mostly
we we work with third party
manufacturers to to integrate our app
with uh with their devices os um so we
have a bunch of instructions that get
passed between the devices os
and the prime video client and then they
need to be in the correct order they
need to be
um you know they need to be sequenced
correctly and sometimes they could be
long running
really hard to test so we decided this
was a perfect use case
for static analysis um
so this is the bit that we're that we're
reasoning about um
and and you know so it allows us to tell
developers whether they got the sequence
right
um and we call these sequences contracts
because we're really kind of enforcing
api contracts with this
with this with these results and so
right now in this layer we have nine
different contracts that we check
when third parties are integrating with
our app
um and so so for example we do things
like we check
that global variables aren't being
tampered with um
you know if uh if a a language or a
local or a time zone gets changed and a
comma gets introduced somewhere
well you know the bad kind of things
that can happen when when those
unexpected nuances change
we also look at things like call back
functions being implemented correctly
which is hard to write a unit or an
integration test for
so coast guard helps us accelerate the
integration process it helps third
teams it helps us get our app on more
devices quicker and at higher quality
uh all right so uh what's next what's
next for coast guard and bug bear well
for coast guard we're extending it to
make more checks
across more areas of the stack does all
these hundreds of teams have
all these integration points with with
critical dependencies on each other
um and we want to we want to leverage
this reasoning
uh all over the place and we're also
beginning to empower
uh developers to write their own
contracts um so they can they can reason
about things
they understand the code better than we
do um so
that's going to be a huge huge piece of
impact for us to have
and then as for bug bear well uh so
we're gonna be adding more analyzers
um not just off-the-shelf ones but
building our own custom analyzers
and so yeah so here's here's a call to
action so if you're uh
maybe you're developing an analyzer uh
that we could integrate with
you know would definitely be interesting
in hearing about your analyzer and if it
can help us
um you know keep raising the quality bar
we really do feel like this is the
tip of the iceberg for the amount of
impact we can have
using these kind of techniques at prime
video
um i'm not sure if i've got time for
questions i'll probably run over a
little bit
um but if anybody has any questions or
has
just posted any in the chat i can't see
the chat so i'm going to end i'm going
to stop sharing my screen
then we'll also have you know at the end
of the session if folks want to
ask questions to any of the speakers um
you know please and even just another
reminder for people who may have joined
late
uh please feel free to type in questions
uh and
some of these people who are not
speaking we can feel them or we can wait
for the speaker
at the end so thanks
jim that was uh that's great and um
moving up the stack a little just uh we
we also have
another code analysis talk uh by leigh
pike
who's a principal scientist in code guru
and he's going to talk about how they're
using machine learning
and program analysis um together
great thanks neha can you hear me and
see my slides
yeah perfect okay yes so thank you yeah
i'm a member of the koguru team and what
i want to
let me oh yeah what i want to do is uh
first of all
tell you about our vision for bringing
machine learning
and automated reasoning to the devops
life cycle so
you know we're all uh fairly familiar
with uh
this uh how we develop applications and
write code
so you know you write code you you
submit
um code reviews we build and test
we deploy the code then you measure it
you instrument it make sure that the
performance is what you expect
and hopefully this results in a virtuous
circle
uh where we keep improving the
application
now it's easy for me to write this
workflow on a slide of course
but this is really difficult in practice
to get this right so
um it requires both uh deep expertise
uh all along here as well as there's a
lot of tedious work to do so
you want deep expertise to review your
code make sure that there's
no issues in there um
instrumenting monitoring your code can
be quite tedious but you also need those
that deep expertise to take the results
of that and understand where that
uh how to improve the software based on
that
so based on that i want to talk about
two services that we have today
to address these issues that bring
machine learning and automated reasoning
to assist developers to provide that
expertise and remove some of the tedium
so very briefly let me mention code guru
reviewer which
helps you automatically find and improve
the performance of your code by finding
hotspots
and helping you understand how to
remediate them
and profilers built using machine
learning
to help automatically
uh improve the code um based on
this dynamic analysis um however what i
want to spend my time uh focusing on
though is cougar reviewer which uh
operates at the beginning of this devops
life cycle so this helps
find and remediate issues in your code
at code review time so um everyone's
familiar with this workflow
you make a code review and you have a
pull request
or and you have other members of your
team
um look at your code and help you try to
make sure you're following best
practices
that there's no security issues that um
you're using uh the code correctly
and so you can think of uh guru
reviewers as an automated
additional reviewer that has been
specially trained to find
uh hard to find issues so it's been
trained on
uh millions of lines of amazon code open
source code
to find uh specific code patterns and
kinds of issues
that that developers might make and help
you remediate them
in particular one thing we've really
worked hard on is reducing the noise and
false
false positives you don't want to wade
through a haystack looking for a needle
uh in terms of findings and so both
machine learning and applying that
automated reasoning can help
re it helps really reduce the number of
false positives so that
the recommendations are actionable of
course this improves with developer
feedback
and uh the breadth of the the
recommendations that you get continues
to uh grow as
as the tool develops
so uh today we support java um and
support
uh amazon code commit github including
github enterprise and bitbucket uh for
uh repos that you can associate with so
i just wanna spend a few minutes just
giving you a sense of some of the kinds
of
uh recommendations that kobu reviewer
can provide today so here's an example
where
a developer may be using a concurrent
hash map so suppose repo is a concurrent
hashmap and in the second
if statement i'm going to ask if it
contains a key ip and if so i get that
key
and what can happen is uh if this is uh
in a concurrent program another thread
may be modifying
the map after i check that
the branch condition and if so i could
have a deep
difficult um bug that's hard to find
because
this only happens in a certain uh
certain instance when
another thread's operating at the exact
right part of my program so these are
the exact kind of things that
are really hard uh to debug
that uh cougar reviewer can help you
with today
so an example in a different domain is
sensitive information links so here's a
aws api
update job status and it can take a
number of parameters and uh
update job status may
uh result in an exception so we're
catching those and that's good
but one thing um is that uh one of our
parameters is this uh
the result of uh get aws account id and
this is something that
um uh may be sensitive and that
customers
um don't want to uh
uh log in in when they're uh catching
an exception and so cougar reviewer
uh can warn you about this and so that
you can follow best practices in terms
of uh redacting uh potentially sensitive
information
so i've given um two examples for these
first two categories uh but there are
several other categories with
numerous uh recommendations that cogury
viewer provides
as well so including best practices
across aws apis
uh ensuring that you are handling um
your resources correctly that you don't
have resource leaks
uh finding other code defects
that you may have uh help with
refactoring so helping find similar
lines of code across your code base
to clean up your code
as well as input validation and not only
is the number of recommendations growing
but also the
the kinds of categories that we check
so just to give you a concrete example
here's
a what a recommendation might look like
in bitbucket
so you can see that a recommendation is
is just like you would see from your
other colleagues
who are reviewing your code um it
provides uh
it shows you exactly where the issue is
um try
explains um how to remediate it and
provides um additional
uh information uh to uh help help
improve code in the future and help
developers understand um
uh the the the issue uh behind the
the specific uh code quality finding
all right um and that's it so uh uh
cougar
is available today you can uh get
started at
this website i'd love to hear uh
feedback from folks and feel free to
send any questions my way all right
thank you very much
awesome um thank you lee we
we are a little ahead of schedule so if
anybody wants to join
or like type in a question or turn on
their audio and ask a question
um we can take one
okay someone's saving themselves for the
q a afterwards
yeah so
i mean if somebody comes up with a
question in the meantime they can but uh
that's right um nathan chong
is next we're going back back down in
the
bits bits of the bowel of um
everything and um
so nathan is our is also a principal
scientist he's working on um
proving memory safety thread safety for
a low-level
uh code and he's going to talk talk to
us about
his experiences and applying it to iot
and other applications so take it away
nathan hey thanks neha and hello cab
it's a privilege to tell you about how
we're applying separation logic
to the free articles kernel so what is
friata's
it may surprise you to learn that even
if you're unfamiliar with the project
you may still have interacted with it
here are some fun examples
both products containing free artists
inside so you see
on the left in this smart plug free
altos may have made you some coffee
or in this oven baked you some fish and
that's because
freertos is a real-time operating system
for microcontrollers which in another
way of putting it is to say that free
rtos
is an ideal building block for devices
in the internet of things or the iot
and this of course is where we're trying
to disperse computation as widely and as
finely as possible
so that we can begin to sense and
actuate the world at large and although
the examples that i gave were all in the
consumer domain
the vision for the iot is vast there's a
great talk at aws re invent 2019 where
volkswagen speak about how the iot is
fundamentally transforming how they're
building cars
and that's really why it's so exciting
to be uh applying
automated reasoning to friatos because
this is a incredibly
widely used codebase with the potential
to be deployed to uh
billions of devices so this is a
block diagram of a fairly typical iot
stack hardware is at the bottom
and the application specific logic is at
the top these are going to differ
depending on the
domain of your iot device friatos is the
set of common functionality in the
middle
and it's both the um portable
abstraction layer of the kernel
and a set of common features for
functionality like network connectivity
so i'm focusing just on the kernel but
this is just one of many pieces of
automated reasoning that we're doing
with friatos
and if you'd like to hear about those i
really encourage you to
reach out in the chat to ask about those
all right then so let's zoom into this
kernel then and talk about
the um primary data structure that can
be used for inter-task
communication which allows for sending
and receiving of data
between different tasks and this is the
kernel cue that you see here
and interestingly this has to work in a
concurrent setting
meaning that we can have multiple
writers multiple readers
arbitrarily sending and receiving and
that these operations can overlap in
time
so there are many interesting aspects to
this data structure but let me highlight
one which is
uh this concurrent setting with tasks
which are entirely standard to the c
consistency model but also interrupt
service routines or isrs
these are pieces of code that run in an
event driven manner
when some hardware interrupt occurs a
good example of an interrupt would be
the wake word of an iot device and isrs
can themselves
interact with the queue and that's
interesting from our point of view
because
tasks and isrs are asymmetric in their
power you see there are things that
tasks can do
for example block that an isr must not
and so
from a specification point of view we
need to be able to adequately deal with
both of these types of
um user so we're talking about
700 lines of c code being designed for
these microcontroller resource
constrained environments
we may only have a few hundred kilobytes
in memory
and this means that we won't necessarily
have features which you would expect in
microprocessors
uh virtual memory address spacing for
example isn't normal in microcontroller
environments by low-level core screen
concurrency i mean that these mechanisms
are really close to the machine
so for example the main mechanism that
we're going to acquire a global lock on
the queue
is to turn off interrupts
on the other hand our requirements for
what we prove about the
um kernel queue are quite deep we want
to have
memory safety we want to have thread
safety and we want to have functional
correctness
and we want this over the code of the
implementation not just the model
so separation logic's a great fit for
this because fundamentally we're
reasoning about
resources and ownership and then within
the space of tooling available to us
we want to explore the more automated
end
verafast is such a tool it's from bart
jacobs
and his colleagues at ku leuven and it's
a deductive verifier for separation
logic
built using symbolic execution fairfax
has been applied to a number of really
interesting industry projects including
java card programs and
linux device drivers so we were really
keen to try it out too
and i think it's time that we took a
look at some code together
so let me first point out that priyatos
is
developed under an mit license and
freely available on
github the same is true for the proofs
that i'm going to show you
let me show you that um vera fast
absolutely lives up to its name
here we're going to run a proof
regression over those 700
lines of implementation 20 functions in
total
we're going to be checking memory safety
thread safety and functional correctness
in about four seconds finally let's peel
back the layer
one more level and look at a proof in a
little more detail just to give you an
essence of what it looks like
this is the very fast ide and the green
bar at the top shows that the proof was
successful
the proof itself is for an internal
function to the queue
api and it's called by the send
operation
when we want to put the contents of this
buffer here
into this queue and ultimately if we
scroll down in the implementation we see
that this is
done in the implementation as a mem copy
call
so we see in the function contract in
particular in the pre-condition
the separating conjunction of separation
logic
is uh essential to ensure that the
source
and the destination of that mem copy are
disjoint
in other words ensuring that the mem
copy is well defined
moreover we are able to express in
verifast
user provider predicates and this is a
shape predicate that captures the
well-formedness of the queue
and in particular allows us to lift the
concrete implementation of the queue
into its abstract representation the
logical
um the logical list of elements inside
the key
this is best seen inside the post
condition here where
after appending to the back of the queue
we see that the resulting data structure
its logical representation is the
original contents of the queue
abs plus this new element x
where x is indeed the symbolic contents
of that buffer that we wanted to enqueue
in the first place
so i hope this gives you a flavor of
what it's like to work inside very fast
and i'll add that this speed that we saw
in the um proof time was really valuable
when we were developing the proofs
for having rapid feedback
let me finish with a quote from
richard barry he's the founder of the
free artist project and a senior
principal here at
amazon and i asked him to comment on the
work to apply
separation logic and all the other
pieces of automated reasoning that we're
doing too
and he said quote demonstrating due
diligence
through the use of these
state-of-the-art best practices
is essential to maintain the confidence
and trust of our user base
and well i just love this quote because
uh any world
in which separation logic is starting to
be seen as
best practice it's a really great one
indeed and i think in
no small part to the work inside this
community
so on that very positive note i'll leave
you there
thank you
awesome any questions
i'll have a look in the chat and follow
up
cool well thank you thank you nathan the
you know very exciting touching all
parts of our
life whether we know it or not um
coming on to the next one uh some of you
may know
the speaker his name is daniel croning
he's
attached to cal in some ways more than
one um
i'm told but it's um
he he recently joined amazon as a
um as a full-time employee so we are
very lucky to have him
and actually talk about uh some of his
work
so welcome daniel thank you very much
now
so um what you've seen is
lee presenting work on how to use
machine learning techniques
in order to verify software okay so
the idea there is that we improve what
we are doing
um to
deliver our usual targets which is to
verify hardware software and similar
things
uh by means of machine learning so
i'm going to flip it around and what i'm
going to explain to you how
the things we already know so meaning
with techniques we have been using
um in in the last 30
40 years or so will help us to improve
machine learning
uh just for a bit of context here
um one of the things i've done was in my
career was the postdoc before clark at
cunningham university
okay and ed clark was always extremely
welcoming
of customers of verification and model
checking in particular
so anyone who came and said like heard
you're doing the samprologic model
checking
business and it could be useful for my
application
his first answer even before i heard
what the application was was yes
okay and he was always very welcoming of
anyone who wanted to use verification
for more or less any purpose this worked
out in some cases extremely well so
a very very high profile example is
hardware verification
and it's it's absolutely fair to say
that any hardware engineer anywhere on
the planet that builds
circuitry a little further of a formal
verification
and model checking you you can go into
any
semiconductor company um and ask them
um how they assure correctness of
circuitry and the answer will very often
involve
um off-the-shelf formal verification
tools model checkers that in essence
buy from the eda industry okay
uh so this story did go on so we have
byron on the call and he can tell you a
lot how
um the progression of the adoption
of software analyzers
um happened in places such as microsoft
and in many many other companies i don't
think we're quite there yet
we are not yet at a point where we can
credibly say that each and every
software engineer on the planet
will necessarily assume that model
checking is a tool that we use on a
daily basis
okay but there's certainly been quite
some progress
so verification has over the years
engaged with many other areas
so i would say that in security um
verification technology is something
which is certainly acknowledged to be
something that's useful to prevent
exploitable security vulnerabilities
but there have been also other
interactions with
with many many research areas for
instance biology or
so very recent applications for instance
include for instance vp analyses of
legal text and
whatnot my view is that
machine learning is one of these
applications so
it's somebody who wants to know
something about their design
okay with various goals in mind so very
very common goal is that you feel that
you might have to improve it or you bet
you want some reassurance
but it does what you intended okay so
what i'm looking at is whether we can
explain what train components are doing
and whether we can get assurances about
them and
perhaps we can find one of the other bug
that will and let us eventually fix it
so the key thing i'm interested in is
how to do that at scale so size matters
here
so we have seen early work in
our community where we have turned
neural networks
into smt formulas this is entirely
feasible
something relatively straightforward to
do this translation
um a neuron in a neural network is in
essence
an if okay so it's an it expression in
in smg lib
um and then you would have a a linear
expression
followed afterward so uh
we have done that and it didn't scale to
a level
are your slides supposed to be advancing
not quite yet i will get there um i will
get there
so back to the point of scale
okay so a neural network of
realistic proportion will have a million
neurons possibly two or three million
neurons okay
whereas the capacity where we're
currently at with our formal reasoning
techniques
might be in the order of a couple of
hundred so there's a big big big
gap in terms of what where we need to be
at
and what we can currently do okay
um furthermore a lot of the traditional
ki processes that the software industry
has
adopted in the past 50 years or so don't
work terribly well for train components
and what i'm referring to here is
model checking but testing processes
let's say
the the qa stack that
jim has mentioned earlier okay so
if you apply this to a trained component
it doesn't quite provide you with
the same level of reassurance that you
normally get from uh using this sort of
technologies
and among all train components deep
neural networks are particularly
problematic and difficult to deal with
in particular behavior of these sort of
components may be surprisingly frail so
this means it has worked for you
many many times when you look at it and
you turn around okay you turn your back
to your computer and when it started
failing and misbehaving and doing things
that you didn't quite expect to do
um the usual answer in the community to
a problem is do validation so this means
collect a lot of data
where you know the answer okay
then you're not supposed to use that
data to train but what you're supposed
to do with that data is to
check if we oh well uh check if we could
if the software that you're building um
would deliver the expected answers on
that validation data set
okay so uh how can we
help okay as as the community but
it's used to building verification
technology um i'm just going to
give you pointers or teasers rather to a
pieces of work
that has been published in this area
so this is about the idea of using
a trained neural network to produce test
inputs okay
specifically adversarial inputs this
means these are inputs which would
trigger
a neural network to deliver a wrong
classification or labeling uh whatever
you want to
to have it so basically just giving you
some some flash images here what we have
on the left is an image which is
correctly classified
in this case as the alps and on the
right hand side it's it's classified as
a bison
okay down here what we have
is a sea snake which turns into
crossword
so i should stress that all of these
inputs have been generated automatically
by
tooling that's obviously designed in
order to to
produce inputs of this case yeah so on
the right inside we have more technology
so we return with rob and a bird into a
keyboard
so again these images are generated yeah
here's another uh piece of work which is
going to be presented at eccv which is a
vision conference
now suppose you have a neural network
that in this case
performs classification how can you
tell what it really does okay so i'm now
considering the case where
the neural network delivers the expected
answer
so you might be under the impression
that it's doing just the right job
okay um so what we see here is a dog
where dog got labeled as a dog so
everything is all right
but why is it a dog okay and what this
technology what i'm showcasing here is
doing is it will
give you a minimalist reason as to why
it's a dog
so um a reason in this case is a subset
of input so everything that's
um in gray here has been masked out and
the
remainder of the picture is in this case
the head of a dog
still gets classified as a dog by the
neural network
okay so this case was worked out
reasonably well and we would say well
you know the reason why this picture is
a dog is because of
this part here okay we might have been
happy with maybe some lower parts as
well but definitely would have been
unhappy
if it used this this toy here um as a
reason why it's a dog
but then on the other hand look at this
image here so yes it's correct in the
sense that
the boy is wearing a cowboy hat so the
classification isn't wrong
so it will pass your validation but the
reason
that the neural network uses to classify
it as a caliber head is maybe not what
we would intuitively expect
so what we see is that this subpart of
the image here which is clearly the
boy's face
and has nothing to do with the cowboy
hat um
is the key reason why the neural network
decided that this is a cowboy hat indeed
okay and that clearly points to
a problem with either the setup of a
training
or the data set that you've been using
in any case that's something that needs
to be fixed
okay so here we have some
data and one of the things i want to do
is just point out is there's a timeline
here so these are competing tools that
use other
kinds of technology um so what is
interesting is the
the progression in that field so what we
see here is the
size of the explanation so meaning how
many of the pixels do you have to put
into the subset of the image before
the neural network will classify your
image in the ferrite label
so obviously this has a point here where
if you give it the entire image we'll
definitely classify it the way it does
okay and there's a point down here where
if you give give it nothing it would be
highly surprising if it gave the right
okay for right text
classification and then there's
something in between okay so
as you grow your explanation as you grow
with subset of the image you would
you would expect to see more and more
correct explanations
so shap was a tool that was pioneering
in this area and as you can see
um you you need to give a pretty large
uh part of the image before it produces
um not even half of the um
of the labels correctly for your uh data
set so
if we are really nearly approaching 100
here
um the tool that produced the
explanation that you've just seen is
called deep cover so that's the blue
line here
uh as in oxford blue of course
okay and as you can see with a
relatively modest
fragment of the image so something like
a third or so
you get a very large number of images
classified in the way you would expect
so what i did want to point out is there
was a couple of other tools rise grad
cam
lime and on extreme have been published
very very recently in the last uh
six months to a year or so and as you
can see
these are getting closer and closer to
the performance of deep coverage so
there's massive and very rapid progress
in this area of research
um so just to give you an idea what sort
of the difference could be between tools
or
algorithms so what you see here is a
number of samples taken from the
classifier so n is the number of times
you create a renault network
and when you see the resulting
explanation being given
so on the right inside you have rise
which is one of the competing tools on
the left hand side you have deep cover
on the very left you have the original
image
so one cool thing about doing research
around image classifiers but you
is that you get to use cute images of
puppies and kittens and centuries
okay so what we can see here is that for
for 2000 samples we get a fairly decent
explanation
for 200 which is very very small amount
of compute used
uh we still get a pretty decent
explanation of what's going on
uh on the other hand if we if you let
rise only have 200 samples when
you can see it starts using pieces of
grass and so on and that's the
explanation which is
really not correct okay um
so i will end things here with just a
bit of advertisement so these are the
references to
work that i've just mentioned and also
to others so so
you can also look at neural networks
that control an agent for instance
uh so meaning they evolve a system over
time
uh so we've looked at work where we
asked the question wherever such trained
agents would satisfy ldl properties
and how would you do that effectively
with
acceptable amounts of compute we've also
looked at the question whether giving
specifications in terms of logic would
let you train better agents meaning
produce
for instance a multi-headed neural
network um
which splits faces of a job that needs
to be done
um and and very in similar things uh so
i'm very happy to send pointers to do
further work in this area if anyone has
questions about it
thank you
thank you daniel um
well as as usual you know fire away
questions for danielle in the in the
chime chat
and uh um we are a little ahead of
schedule but
like we'll we'll keep going we'll keep
powering through uh
last but not least uh we have uh
byron cook um who started the automated
reasoning group
about five years ago at amazon and
he's gonna talk about some of the
exciting new things that he's
working on himself he's he's
um has been in his uh
like i'll say basement even though he's
technically on like the second floor
it's just it's a it's a more powerful
image he's been in his basement hacking
away
and so i'll heal the florida him
for him to tell us about it awesome can
you see my screen
can you hear me yes we can hear you now
awesome so this is my name my byron
here's my email address firing at amazon
it's pretty
easy to remember so uh so here are some
tools we know and love
perhaps you've used them and the thing
about these tools and basically all of
the tools that we use in our community
is that they're built with the
assumption that you're running on a
single computer they're typically built
by someone
who ran them on a laptop and they ran
them very
effectively and they have deep
understanding of the tool or or the
tools have made a bunch of decisions
based on the assumption that they're
running on a single computer
and so for example if we look at sv comp
and look at the
environment in which uh contestants are
competing
we're limited to eight processing units
of cpu
and so the question emerges today is
like
like why do we have this limitation
right because the thing is like
aside from the formal methods community
everyone else has moved to massively
distributed systems so the entire world
if you look at all of the customers of
cloud
uh they're running massive distributed
systems across
thousands uh tens of thousands of
computers so there's a for example on
aws
we have a global and exponentially
growing amount of compute resources
available on the cloud currently there's
24
regions there's three new regions that
have been announced and
and then in each region of the world
there's multiple what they call
availability zones
uh so there's 77 availability zones
currently worldwide
and this this is a slide uh i i
mentioned this in my
uh flock plenary talk uh
two years ago but it's worth mentioning
because it sort of
gives some idea of the scale so in 2015
aws that's amazon's cloud offering
uh added enough capacity every day
to run all of the amazon.com in 2005.
so that's enough new computers to run a
fortune 500 company
every day and that was in 2015 and what
we've seen
since 2015 is continued exponential
growth so
every year essentially aws has grown
fifty percent year over year
so you can take this number and uh and
then take fifty percent year over year
over uh the the next five years to sort
of work out
uh some idea of how much computers how
many computers we're adding
every day into aws so we have compute
and we have databases and we have
storage for example and all of these are
distributed
compute and storage services for various
performance character
characteristics you need so for example
if you need states you would
one of one of the good services for very
fast
distributed eventually consistent uh uh
state is dynamic db
um another example would be q so sqs
called the simple q
service is a is a q api
that's distributed and eventually
consistent
and then we have both serverless and
server based computation so if you want
a thousand
linux machines in the sky you use ec2
and if you just want to pass
code to a service and you have and you
have no idea
how it's operating that or on exactly
what kind of computer it's operating on
it then you'd use
lambda for example so so the question
that
uh has been
emerging in my head uh over the essence
joining amazon is
like why would you write uh proof search
programs
for this comp to this computer a laptop
when you could write
programs for this computer right this is
a big computer
that we can program right so we can have
distributed algorithms
looking for a single proof over
thousands of computers
and and and our on our and we can find
in
eventually consistent uh invariants or
eventually consistent
proofs over our first single problem and
one of the charming aspects of
mathematical proof is it's only the
final argument that really matters right
you can do complete voodoo uh along the
way
and and add case splits as you like uh
you could
you could base your reasoning based on
flawed assumptions but so long as
in the sat solver you eventually
find a a proof that that that
hold by the by the proof system that is
not solver or in a
symbolic model checker if you find an
inductive invariant
right that could be the representation
of the bdd the interpolants you find
what what have you then no matter how
you got there so long as ultimately you
have
a proof then you're done and so you can
uh distribute that search over many
machines
and they may be out of sync as they're
doing uh proof search but so long as it
converges eventually
into a consistent inductive invariant
then then that's that's all you need
that's all you're going to need to care
about so the validity of induction
or or or the sap instances
can be proved typically in linear time
very easily
independently and actually in in
parallel separately right so it's it's
the
act of finding a proof and checking your
proof are really independent and they
can vote they can both be done
in a massively distributed way uh
so and then if you look at many of our
symbolic algorithms
and i should i should point out that the
concrete
algorithms like say concrete like
explicit state model checking
has has been making use of distributed
systems and concurrency forces for some
while but in the symbolic
uh uh reasoning area where we're quite
behind but actually
many of these algorithms are sort of
ready for distribution with with a bit
of work so if we take for example
uh ken's paper from cabo six it's a
it's uh he's describing a tool called
impact and this is sort of the
uh ultimate interpolation based symbolic
model checker so so
what ken does is he introduces uh here i
have
from figure four of the paper there's a
few other operations but basically
uh four operations that
uh you can execute in any order uh
to find an inductive invariant over the
program
right and so uh so we're
we're we're bill in this in ken's paper
what he's doing is he's
he's unfolding the control flow graph
into a tree and then trying to limit the
space of the the growth of that tree
by finding back edges which which
represent the
current candidate for an inductive
invariant and there's no reason that
this needs to be executed on a
sequential machine in fact there's no
reason this needs to be executed
on a machine you can imagine many
different machines
all uh editing this graph and so long as
we eventually find a consistent
proof by induction then then we're done
so with a bit of care
we can call expand refine and those
cover steps and then there's a few other
steps in ken's paper
uh on many machines in an eventually
consistent graph
and and and now distribute uh distribute
perhaps perhaps in uh uh you know like
you get
speed ups that are linear with respect
to the um number of processors you use
who knows
um and so another really promising uh
result
is is i don't i don't know if you're
following the sat competition but there
was a new track
in the sac competition this year uh
called the cloud track
and uh the new cloud solver so these are
distributed
eventually consistent solvers uh are
solving problems that none of the other
solvers can solve
so there were 250 instances where no
sequential solver could solve them in
300
3000 seconds but the cloud solvers which
which
which distributed the proof search and
set over many machines
were able to solve them
so some questions going on my in my head
what what are the proof techniques that
we need that take advantage
of the world's largest and fastest
growing computer
right so that's the question that's been
uh
going through my head and now i'm taking
some time to try and try and build that
what are the assumptions uh that are no
perhaps no longer relevant
maybe uh
lazy for example uh the lazy loop
right where you uh okay sort of counter
example guided abstraction refinement or
the
the method of abstracting from theories
to sets
maybe that sort of works really well on
the unit processor or a single machine
case but maybe that doesn't uh make as
much sense in a distributed model
i'm not sure and so what if we were to
take
a clean sheet of paper call like a a4
and and try again but with the mind of
the a
where we're gonna the construction of
proof certificates is is
a feature from day one and also that
we're gonna
always execute this on a distributed uh
global machine right and if those are
the
uh constraints now as opposed to we're
going to run this really
on a you know pentium microprocessor
really fast
then there's really a different set of
of um
[Music]
of decisions we're probably going to
make and that's that's uh something i'm
working on now and so
i think i'm the last speaker so uh i'm
now gonna
end my talk there and i'm happy to take
questions both about
uh this thing i've been talking about
but also i'd be happy to take questions
about
uh formal reasoning in amazon more
generally thanks
thank you byron
questions comments